سعودي سنرصد الان الاحتفالات في الشارع
واحتفالات الماره في فوز المنتخب السعودي
الذي حقق فوز كبير الفرحه هنا في كل مكان
الاعلام على السيارات التي تمر بالشوارع
هنا ايضا ازدحام في الحركه المروريه همم
بسبب الاعداد الكبيره المتوافده الى
الاماكن العامه للاحتفال بفوز المنتخب
السعودي اضافه الى وجود العديد من المناطق
الاخرى التي تتوفر سواء من وزاره الرياضه
او حتى من همم الهيئه العامه للترفيه التي
وفرت منطقه داخل استاد ملعب مرسول مبارك
للتشجيع ومشاهده مباريات المنتخب السعودي
خلال همم المنافسات اضافه الى توفير همم
العديد من المناطق الاخرى في الاماكن
العامه الجميع هنا متحمس ومتفاعل مع فوز
المنتخب على الرغم من اداء الطلبه
لاختبارات النهائيه او الاختبارات الفصليه
الا ان الفرحه وصرخات الجماهير فقط على
همم هذا الحدث بفوز المنتخب السعودي
وتحقيق الفوز على الارجنتين الذي حتى
الجماهير العربيه خالد تحدثنا مع قبل قليل
وكانوا يتحدثون بانهم لم يتوقعوا هذا
الفوز على منتخب قوي ومعروف ويحقق دائما
الفوز على الارجنتين ولكن ربما تكون
السنوات الماضيه استراتيجيه وزاره الرياضه
دعم الكبير للقطاع الرياضي حقق هذا التقدم
تطور اللاعبين تحفيز الامير محمد بن سلمان
لاعبين المنتخب قبل الانتقال والتوجه الى
قطر للعب في منافسات المونديال كانت هي
الدافع الاول نتوقع ايضا خالد ان تتوافد
جماهير اكبر الى قطر تتوجه لدعم المنتخب
حقيقه بعدها هذا الفوز الكبير خاصه وان
اجراءات همم السفر الى قطر مسهله كثيرا
لجميع الجماهير مشاعر جميله نشهدها هنا في
الرياض واحتفالات من الجميع المواطنين
والمقيمين يفرحون بهذا الفوز كونه يشكل
فوز او انتصار عربي لمنتخب عربي وهو
المنتخب السعودي الذي حقق هذا الفوز اليوم
نعم